three-two-one John's a strong silent
type a man a few words the tiger king
has quickly become the hottest show on
Netflix because it's almost unbelievable
want to know exactly how Joe xotic used
baby tigers keep watching for 10 of the
darkest secrets from the tiger king
documentary Carol's missing husband
everyone is talking about what happened
to dawn Lewis Carroll Baskins missing
husband but no one seems to talk about
how toxic their relationship was from
the beginning Don was already married
with children when he saw Carol walking
down the street crying he kept trying to
get her in the car with him they had an
affair for four years before they got
married but Don was also unfaithful to
Carol for their whole marriage he even
had a girlfriend down in Costa Rica Don
had money when he met Carol Carol pretty
much had nothing Joey exotics parents in
Episode one Joe says that his
relationship with his father was not
great when Joe came out as gay his
father shook his hand and made him
promise not to come to his funeral but
years later Joe is back to having a
relationship with his mom and dad this
relationship was not exactly healthy
though his mom said he would just give
her papers to sign that she didn't even
read this got her into a huge financial
bind dock animals workers Joe exotic
considers dock handle to be his big cat
mentor doc has several women that he
considers his wives they work 18-hour
days seven days a week at one point they
lived in horse stalls with sliding doors
doc controls what they eat and what they
wear one former worker said that she was
forced into getting plastic surgery they
also have to call him a given which
apparently means Lord expired meat one
of the ways that Joe xotic managed to
feed all the big cats at the GW
interactive zoo involved expired meat he
would get a big truck of recently
expired meat from Walmart this might be
fine for feline predators with highly
acidic stomachs but his workers
struggled to make ends meet they would
take meat off the truck because they
couldn't afford much else later when
Jeff Lowe builds a pizza place on site
we find out the
the meat on the pieces was also expired
Oh gross we aren't sure how the health
department didn't shut them down
political publicity stunts if Joey
exotic running for political office
seems strange to you you're not alone it
was weird for everyone in his life to at
first Joe tried to run as an independent
in the 2016 presidential election then
he turned his sights to the governor's
office used graphic language in all his
promos and handed out contraception with
his face on it but his campaign manager
and other people close to him have said
it was nothing more than a publicity
stunt Joe wanted nothing more than to
become famous and somehow he won 19
percent of the vote worker pay the
people who work with big cats put their
lives on the line every day but they get
paid pennies Joe's workers only made
about $20 a day he would provide them
housing but they were infested with
pests and didn't even have working
appliances at least he paid them Carol
Baskin doesn't pay any of her workers
these volunteers must give up holidays
and go through expensive training they
work long hours for no money want to
know what happens to Joe's baby tigers
keep watching to find out
Travis Maldonado Joe's second husband
Travis Maldonado is one of the saddest
stories from the show Joe used Travis's
addiction to keep him around
Travis was only 19 when they got married
he became depressed and felt very
trapped he had a habit of winning loaded
weapons at people when
was under the influence but when he
pointed it at himself it ended badly he
said he didn't think it was loaded but
it was did he plan it all along or was
it really an accident for the camera
Joe exotic loves being on camera he
wants to be the center of attention all
the time and he was always putting on a
show he did it at Travis's funeral but
he also did a lot for the reality show
that was being filmed in fact he would
lose his temper and fire people just
because he wasn't on camera
Jeff Lowe's motives I'm not an angel of
God talking about it's not clear how
involved Jeff Lowe was in the plot to go
after Carroll Baskins everyone says
something different but it is clear that
he wanted Jo out of the picture he said
it himself in the last episode then he
went on and took advantage of Tim stark
after Tim paid for a new zoo baby Tigers
one of the most heartbreaking moments of
the series was when we learned what
happens to tiger cubs jo was illegally
breeding the big cats when a tiger gave
birth he pulled the cubs away as soon as
they were born they didn't even get a
chance to nurse they cried non-stop the
first few days because they were taken
from their mothers it was even suggested
that he sold them to pay for the hit on
Carol which moment in Tiger King left
you most surprised let us know in the
comments thanks for tuning in don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to the things for more great content see
you next time
you